[Musik]
[Applaus]
wusstet ihr dass es ein Land gibt das
drei Präsidenten gleichzeitig hat und
bei all den Problemen die schon ein
einziges Staatsoberhaupt alleine
verursachen kann stellt euch vor ihr
hättet gleich drei auf einmal nun ein
solches Land ist Bosnien Herzegowina
dieses Land ist aber nicht nur wegen
seiner drei Präsidenten einen genaueren
Blick wert obwohl die allein schon den
Stoff zu einem eigenen Video liefern
würden das wirklich heiße Thema jedoch
ist der Friedensvertrag der Boss in
herzogena seit den Jugoslawien kriegen
zusammenhält denn dieser steht zunehmend
in Zweifel wir werden heute über ein
Land sprechen das während der Kriege in
den 90er Jahren massiv Split und von
deren nach denen es sich bis heute nicht
ganz erholt hat so herrschen dort
inzwischen wieder turbulente
innenpolitische Verhältnisse und der
Nationalismus nimmt erneut zu das alles
spielt sich nur knappe 500 km entfernt
von Deutschland ab quasi vor unserer
Haustür und trotzdem hört man davon
wenig in den Medien obwohl zudem mehr
als eine viertel Millionen Bosnia in
Deutschland Österreich oder Schweiz
leben aber lasst uns mit dem
naheliegendsten beginnen habt ihr euch
auch schon mal gefragt warum ist
eigentlich Bosnien und Herzegowina heißt
tatsächlich handelt es sich um zwei
historische Regionen die Herzegowina
bildet den äußersten Süden des Landes
und macht etwa ein Fünftel seiner Fläche
aus und der Rest des Landes entspricht
dem historischen Bosnien wenn es jedoch
eine Sache gibt die in diesem Land
wirklich ungewöhnlich ist dann sind es
seine Grenzen wird mal einen Blick auf
diese Karte
[Musik]
wie ihr seht ist Bosnien Herzegowina ein
Binnenland bzw fast mit Ausnahme eines
ca 20 km breiten Streifens Küste am
Adriatischen Meer doch dieser kleine
Streifen Küste könnte vor kurzem
vielleicht für jeden wirtschaftlichen
Nutzen und brauchbar gemacht worden sein
und zwar mit Hilfe der EU aus dem
Herzegowina hat nämlich nicht nur
interne Probleme sondern auch Probleme
mit seinen Nachbarn aber dazu später
mehr
entscheidend für die internen Probleme
hingegen sind die Grenzen innerhalb des
Landes zwischen der Föderation von
Bosnien und Herzegowina auf der einen
Seite und der Republica subscar auf der
anderen aber das alles wird euch
wahrscheinlich wenig überraschen denn
falls ihr letzte Woche unser Video über
die Geschichte der Jugoslawien gesehen
habt wisst ihr das im Wesentlichen schon
falls nicht solltet ihr euch dieses
Video unbedingt vorher ansehen ich werde
euch unten verlinken denn den Grund für
das alles finden wir wie immer in der
Geschichte und die ist im Fall dieses
Landes eine echte Tragödie die vor allem
auch in der aktuellen Politik noch nicht
überwunden ist die Fragen die wir uns
heute stellen werden lauten daher warum
hatte Bosnien am Ende gleich drei
Präsidenten warum ist der alte
Friedensvertrag allmählich mal rote
geworden und was hat er gerade erwähnte
Küstenstreifen eigentlich damit zu tun
welche Bedeutung haben die Konflikte in
Bosnien immer in jedem Ort in den mit
dem Attentat von saraje wo der erste
Weltkrieg begann für das Europa von
heute in diesem Video werden wir alle
diese Fragen beantworten und wie immer
werfen wir hierzu zuerst ersten Blick in
die Geschichte
die 21 Tage von Dayton
und die Grenzen des heutigen
Bosnien-Herzegowina zu verstehen müssen
wir ziemlich weit in der Zeit
zurückgehen genauer gesagt bis zum Ende
des 17 jahrhunderts dieser Zeit wurde
der größte Teil des Balkans von den
osmanenkontrolliert doch nicht der ganze
Balkan
du brauchst nicht etwa eine wunderschöne
Stadt im heutigen Kroatien war
unabhängig sie war damals als der
Republik Ragusa bekannt auch die
Republik Venedig mischte in der Region
seit längerer Zeit mit so eroberten die
Venezianer immer wieder Gebiete entlang
der dalmatinischen Küste die heute
übrigens ebenfalls zu Kroatien gehört
tatsächlich hatten damals jedoch die
Venezianer bereits die Grenzen der
Republik Ragusa erreicht und was glaubt
ihr was die Herrscher von Dubrovnik vor
300 Jahren da gemacht haben
nun ihre Reaktion war vielleicht plump
aber effektiv sie ließen die Osmanen
einen landpuffer zwischen sich und den
Venezianern schaffen dazu übergaben sie
20 km Küstenstreifen im Norden des
Stadtstaats in dem die Stadt Neon liegt
an das mächtige Osmanische Reich auf
diese Weise waren sie vor einer
möglichen Land Invasion durch die
Venezianer geschützt tja und der Deal
funktioniert denn Ragusa blieb bis in
die napoleonische Zeit hinein unabhängig
diese Schenkung an die Osmanen ist der
Grund warum Bosnien-Herzegowina heute ca
20 km Küste kontrolliert eben die 20 km
um die Stadt Neum herum die einst an die
Osmanen gegangen waren das restliche
Gebiet der ehemaligen Republik Ragusa
gehört heute zu Kroatien um die anderen
Aspekte zu erklären die Bosnien zu einem
so ungewöhnlichen Land machen müssen wir
nicht so weit zurückgehen
[Musik]
nur bis in den 1990er Jahre vor etwa 30
Jahren zerfiel das ehemalige Jugoslawien
in dem seine Teilrepubliken begann ihre
Unabhängigkeit zu verkünden 1992 war
bossin Herzegowina an der Reihe und wie
bei den vorangegangenen
unabhängigkeitserklärungen gab
Jugoslawien seine Teile Republik nicht
kampflos auf es war der Beginn eines der
schlimmsten Kapitel während der
Jugoslawien Kriege Bosnien wurde
weitestgehend verwüstet während dieses
Krieges 10.000 Menschen starben und
hunderttausende mussten ihre Heimat
verlassen
drei Seiten kämpfen damals gegeneinander
die muslimischen Bosniaken kämpften ums
Überleben die anderen Kriegsparteien
wollten Bosnien unter sich aufteilen und
wurden dabei von Serbien bzw von
Kroatien unterstützt das waren zum einen
die katholischen bosnischen Kroaten und
zum anderen die christliche orthodoxen
bosnischen Serben zu Beginn des Krieges
sah sehr danach aus als würden die
bosnischen Serben gewinnen
die Beherrschten bereits mehr als die
Hälfte des Landes und nutzten ihre
Vormachtstellung um ihre eigene Republik
auszurufen die Republica subscard doch
als ich Bosniaken und bosnische Kroaten
gegen diese Übermacht Verbündeten begann
sich das Blatt zu wenden der
Bosnienkrieg gehört dabei zu den
blutigsten kriegen der jüngeren
Geschichte alle Seiten begingen
barbarische groll-taten hatte man einen
langsprecher erobert begann man ihn von
anderen Ethnien zu säubern nebenbei
bemerkt ist es nicht ein und denken dass
bei all der sprachhygiene die heutzutage
betrieben wird ein kruder Euphemismus
die Säuberung für totalen systematischen
Massenmord und Vertreibung noch immer
zum ganz normalen Sprachgebrauch gehört
also liebe kulturkänzler nehmt euch doch
bitte mal dieser wirklich schlimmen
Beschönigung an ich danke euch doch
weiter im Text den bosnischen Serben
gelang es bald die Hauptstadt Sarajevo
zu umzingeln und sie begann umgehend mit
der Belagerung diese dauerte mehr als
zwei Jahre und forderte viele zivile
Opfer teils wegen starkem Betriebe
Schuss teils wegen Scharfschützen die
lange ihr Unwesen trieben noch schlimmer
war es ins referenza bei Massaker
handelte es sich um den größten
Völkermord des gesamten Bosnienkriegs
der auch so schon von grausam Verbrechen
geprägt war dort töteten die bosnischen
Serben mehr als 8000 bosnische Muslime
überwiegend Jungen und Männer und man
darf nicht vergessen dass solche
Ereignisse in den allermeisten Fällen
von weiteren goldtaten begleitet werden
während des Bosnienkriegs zählten etwa
Vergewaltigungen zum Kriegsalltag und
wurden auch gezielt als eine Art Waffe
gegen die Zivilbevölkerung eingesetzt
vor diesem Hintergrund beschloss der
besten zu intervenieren und die NATO
startete eine dreiwöchige luftkampagne
die Operation delivered Force und da
wurde den bosnischen Serben klar dass
sie keine andere Wahl hatten als zu
verhandeln der Krieg in Bosnien hatte
dreieinhalb Jahre gedauert das Land war
verwüstet die Hälfte Bevölkerung war
ethnisch gesäubert worden das heißt
ermordet oder vertrieben worden mehr als
100.000 Menschen waren gestorben und um
ein Friedensabkommen zu erreichen
mussten die Führer der Bosniaken der
Kroaten und der Serben 21 Tage lang auf
einem US Luftwaffenstützpunkt in Dayton
Ohio eingesperrt werden die
Verhandlungen Daten waren C und verloren
sich oft im Details es musste noch um
das letzte kleine Dorf gerungen werden
ob es nun auf der einen oder anderen
Seite der Grenze liegen sollte und was
ist am Ende dabei herausgekommen gibt
uns der Name des Landes Bosnien und
Herzegowina vielleicht ein Hinweis
darauf nun ja nicht so wirklich man
teilte das Land in zwei politische
Entitäten aber nicht direkt in Bosnien
auf der einen und Herzegowina auf der
anderen Seite die beiden Entitäten aus
den besteht sind viel mehr wie gesagt
die Republica saska und die Föderation
von Bosnien und Herzegowina
[Musik]
die Republica wird weiterhin vor allem
von christlich-orthodoxen bosnischen
Serben bewohnt während ihr dafür
Föderation von Bosnien Herzegowina
mehrheitlich muslimische bosnierten
Gesamtbevölkerung des Landesstellen und
bosnische Kroaten leben und diese
Föderation von Bosnien und Herzegowina
besteht wiederum aus zehn Kantonen
[Musik]
fünf davon sind mehrheitlich von Bozen
Jacken bewohnt drei haben eine
kroatische Mehrheit und in der anderen
beiden ist es kompliziert schon
US-Präsident Clinton sagte während die
Verhandlungen Daten noch liefen kommt
schon belastet bei dem gemischten
Ethnien sonst seid Ihr hier noch mal
weitere 21 Tage lang in Dayton
eingesperrt und dann müssen wir euch
dafür die Hotelrechnung schicken die
alles andere als billig wird ja ich weiß
das klingt wie ein Scherz aber Präsident
Clinton hatte Grund zu dieser Äußerung
denn die Gebiete sollten nach den
Ethnien gebildet werden die in ihnen
leben da musste eben um jedes Dorf
gestritten werden ob es eher dieser oder
eher jener Ethnie zugehört das erklärt
auch den Flickenteppich von
verwaltungsdistriken aus denen das Land
heute zusammengesetzt ist auf dieser
Karte seht ihr alle Teile von
Bosnien-Herzegowina
und diese zeigt noch mal speziell die
Föderation von Bosnien und Herzegowina
und ihre zehn Kantone
[Musik]
könnt ihr nun besser verstehen dieser
Flickenteppich ist wesentlich das
Ergebnis der Verhandlungen in Dayton
oder wirkt sich bis heute auf vieles aus
zum Beispiel auf die Infrastruktur denn
es ist oft kompliziert entsprechende
Projekte zwischen den Vertretern mehrere
Ethnien zu organisieren etwa Banja Luka
der regierungsliste Republik aus subska
und Sarajevo die offizielle Hauptstadt
des Landes liegen Luftlinie 139 km
auseinander die kürzeste
Straßenverbindung ist jedoch 190 km lang
und man braucht drei Stunden für diese
Strecke der Flickenteppich wirkt sich
auch auf das schullesen aus in dem die
ethnischen Gruppen säuberlich getrennt
werden und natürlich wirkt er sich auch
auf die Politik aus in der Trennung der
Ethnien findet sich so auch der Grund
warum das Land 3 Präsidenten zugleich
hat jeder von ihnen repräsentiert eine
der großen ethnischen Gruppen Bosniaken
Serben und Kroaten kurz um ihr könnt
euch sicher vorstellen dass das Leben in
einem derart fragmentierten einem
gesellschaftlich politisch und
logistisch unglaublich zerklüfteten Land
verdammt kompliziert und verwirrend sein
so gesehen müssen ja auf diese Weise bis
heute für all den Hass bezahlen der
durch den Zerfall des ehemaligen
Jugoslawiens entstanden ist und es
bleibt die Frage wie hat das ganze
angesichts des Riesenchaos und des
vielen bösen Blutes bisher überhaupt
irgendwie funktioniert und vor allem wie
wird es jetzt weitergehen aufgepasst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
drei Ethnien zwei Bundesstaaten und eine
Sezession
[Applaus]
habt ihr jemals gedacht dass euer Land
zu viele Politiker hat dann seht euch
doch mal Bosnien an und denkt noch mal
darüber nach vor dem Krieg lebten dort 4
Millionen Menschen heute sind es kaum
noch 3 Millionen zum Vergleich das sind
einige hunderttausend weniger als in
Berlin leben und das ist ja schon ein
recht dünn besiedelter Fleck
trotz dieser kleinen Bevölkerung hat
Bosnien drei Präsidenten einen
Premierminister 12 weitere regionale
Premierminister und 14 Parlamente mit
etwa 700 Parlamentariern und glaubt
nicht eine Sekunde dass wir von einer
Art subsidiären Dezentralisierung im
Stil der Schweiz sprechen ganz und gar
nicht eher von einem politisch
bürokratischen verwaltungsmonster wie
wir es in einigen Mittelmeerländern
vorfinden können
[Applaus]
und das alles in einem der ärmsten
Länder Europas in denen die öffentlichen
Dienstleistungen durchaus einiges zu
wünschen übrig lassen nicht zuletzt
deswegen weiß ich eben die verschiedenen
Ethnien nicht auf ein weniger
kompliziertes Zusammenleben einigen
konnten denn es war versucht dieses
System Gleichberechtigung zwischen den
Medien herzustellen auf der anderen
Seite per patuiert ist aber auch deren
Trennung und das ist wohl einer der
Gründe warum die dortigen Politiker
heute immer noch oft über die ethnischen
Themen streiten die das Land als
maßgeblich in den Bürgerkrieg getrieben
haben dazu kommt noch ein relativ hohes
Maß an Korruption und trotz ihrer Größe
vergleichsweise schwache Institutionen
was das System noch zusätzlich
ineffizient macht vor diesem Hintergrund
wandern viele junge Menschen einfach aus
sobald sie nur die Möglichkeit dazu
haben das erzeugt nicht nur einen
massiven braindrian ins Ausland zum
verschärft auch noch die demografischen
Probleme im Nachhinein betrachtet hat
das Entdecken geschaffenes System also
wohl mehr den nationalistischen
Politikern in Bosnien genutzt als das
ist dem langfristigen Wohl der gesamten
Bevölkerung bedient hätte
[Musik]
und in diesem vergifteten Umfeld
versucht dann zu allem Überfluss auch
noch Potenz den Balkan zu
destabilisieren wie wir in einem
früheren Video berichtet haben fühlen
sich die bosnischen Serben ähnlich den
Kosovo Serben schon seit Monaten von
Russland in ihren separatistischen
Bestrebungen unterstützt der beistandel
war wohl auch ein wichtiger Grund dafür
dass das Parlament der Republik als ka
im Dezember beschlossen sich von den
Streitkräften der Justiz und dem
Steuersystem des restlichen Landes zu
lösen und eigene Wege zu gehen das hat
die USA und die Briten dann veranlasst
den drittens hier hinter dieser Aktion
persönlich zu sanktionieren und die EU
hat ihn immerhin explizit gerückt es
geht um keinen geringeren als einen der
drei Präsidenten dort in herzegowinaas
Milorad deutlich er ist das serbische
Vertreter im präsidentschaftsführung
Verrat und bekannt für seine markigen
Wahlkampfauftritte der Grund für die
Sanktionen war dass er andeutete er
wolle im Namen der bosnischen Serben
ihre russischen Freunde um Hilfe bitten
falls die NATO gegen die
separatistischen Bestrebungen
intervenieren würdet es ist nicht das
erste Mal mit der Abspaltung der
republikas Absagen gedroht hätte aber
wie ihr euch denken könnt ist die ganze
Sache nach der russischen Invasion in
die Ukraine deutlich bekannter geworden
nun vorerst müssen sie aber noch etwas
Geduld haben
der bosnische Serbenführer doll dir
gesagt dass der Krieg in der Ukraine die
abspaltungspläne verzögert hat im Moment
ist das Ganze erstmal um 6 Monate
verschoben worden aber der Plan steht
noch und sieht vor dass die republiker
selbst kam mit der Ausarbeitung neuer
und eigener Gesetze beginnen wird darin
soll festgelegt werden dass die
bosnischen Serben ihre eigenen Steuern
eintreiben ihre Richter selbst ernennen
und ihre eigene Armee aufstellen können
die Sache ist also hochgradig brisant
besonders vor dem Hintergrund dennoch
offenen Wunden der Kriegsjahre noch
immer werden bisher unentdeckte
Massengräber gefunden sodass viele
Menschen ihre ermordeten Angehörigen
identifizieren und bestatten müssen dies
hat auch viel damit zu tun dass nun
viele in die Jahre gekommen ist Soldaten
im Alter oder gar auf dem Totenbett ein
Bedürfnis entwickeln doch noch irgendwie
mit ihrem Gewissen ins Reine zu kommen
und da hat die Position der von ihnen
angelegten Massengräber preisgeben und
in dieser angespannten Atmosphäre spielt
das herrenpräsident deutlich auch noch
die Beteiligung der bosnische Serben an
den völkermorgen während des Krieges
systematisch herunter bzw leugnet sie
manchmal vollkommen je für die bosnische
Serben nicht die einzigen
ministerparatistischen Gelüsten welche
die Einheit Bosnien-Herzegowinas
gefährden
die bosnischen Kroaten beschweren sich
nämlich schon seit Jahrzehnten darüber
dass jeder Einwohner der Föderation an
den Wahlen des kroatischen Vertreters
für das Präsidentenamt teilnehmen darf
nicht nur die bosnischen Kroaten eine
Situation die von den bosnisch
kroatischen Nationalisten natürlich
ausgenutzt wird besonders während oder
kurz nach dem Wahlkampf wird immer
wieder behauptet dass der jeweils
gewählte Präsident nicht den Willen der
Kroaten repräsentiere sondern von den
bosnischen Muslimen quasi an die Macht
gepusht wurde
[Musik]
dieser Protest verstärkt sich in Zeiten
wie diesen wenn der bosnisch kroatische
Vertreter für die Präsidentschaft eher
ein gemäßigtes als ein nationalistisches
Profil zeigt und aus diesem Grund
schließen sich zur Zeit die bosnisch
kroatischen nationalistischen Parteien
zusammen um Änderungen im Wahlgesetz zu
fordern dabei sind sie auch bereit bis
zum Äußersten zu gehen und drohen mit
einem Boykott der Parlamentswahlen die
im nächsten Oktober stattfinden werden
bosnische Kroaten wollen auf
Unabhängigkeit drängen wenn das
Wahlgesetz nicht geändert wird wie ihr
seht befindet sich der Staat aus dem
Herzegowina in einer sehr kritischen
Phase wieder die Politiker ethnische
Unterschiede zu ihren Zwecken ausnutzen
und sogar verschärfen das gilt für
bosnische Kroaten die für bosnische
Serbien mit anderen Worten in
Bosnien-Herzegowina Gerd ist wie schon
lange nicht mehr und die Einheit des
Landes wird zunehmend in Frage gestellt
aber wartet hier einen Moment denn das
ist noch nicht alles erinnert ihr euch
noch an den kleinen Küstenstreifen für
dessen Bedeutung ich euch noch eine
Erklärung schuldig bin also hört jetzt
gut zu denn hier geht das Schlamassel
erst so richtig los
[Musik]
eine Brücke die von Europa wegführt
Bosnien Herzegowina hat sich vor sechs
Jahren das heißt 2016 um die Aufnahme in
die Europäische Union beworben jedoch
hat Brüssel dem Land damals nicht mal
den offiziellen Kandidatenstatus zu
erkannt und so verfügt es bis heute nur
über einen Status eines potentiellen
beitragskandidaten der
Annäherungsprozess zwischen Sarajevo und
der EU hat schon eine längere Geschichte
und ist auf dem Weg immer wieder zu
erliegen gekommen bis 2016 gab es zwar
einige Fortschritte vor allem im
sozioökonomischen Bereich doch stellte
die EU 14 weitere reformansprüche auf
als Bedingung für die weitere Ernährung
sie betreffen vor allem die
Institutionen wie das Justizsystem Grund
und Freiheitsrechte und allgemein den
Kampf gegen die Korruption doch seither
hat sich nicht viel getan Ende 2091
stellte man in Brüssel
Bosnien-Herzegowina einen gerade zu
vernichtendes Zeugnis aus indem du
geringfügige Fortschritte attestiert
wurden nur einer der 14 von Brüssel
vorgegebenen Punkte wurde einigermaßen
erfüllt die folgende Erklärung gab
Oliver der eu-kommiss meine
Nachbarschaftspolitik und Erweiterung
Mitte Juni ab so disstage
priorities that
in European and which Ross come from by
European Council at the time with still
waiting the country
die Treffen mit den europäischen
Institutionen dauern an doch die
internen Spannungen machen es braucht
den Herzogin wieder schwer die von
Brüssel geforderten Reformen
durchzuführen dennoch wird besonders von
der EU-Seite her immer wieder ein
perspektivischer Beitritt aus dem
herzogenas betont nicht zuletzt im
letzten Jahr von der Deutschen
ex-bundeskanzlerin auch wenn sich dies
so anfühlt als sei es Ewigkeiten her und
die Begeisterung für die Europäische
Union hat sich vor Ort allmählich
abgekühlt ja sogar in Enttäuschung
verwandelt
Merkel hat auf ihrer Reise auch auf ein
großes Problem bei der ganzen Sache
hingewiesen nämlich das nicht nur die
Europäer interessiert sind an Einfluss
in der Region und wenn wir nicht an
einer engeren Bindung interessiert sind
so findet sich schnell ein anderer und
wie gesagt der könnte durchaus Putin
heißen aktuell stehen die Dinge also
alles andere als gut abgesehen vom
stockenden Annäherungsprozess muss man
in Bosnien Herzegowina nun mit ansehen
wie man von der Ukraine und Moldawien
rechts überholt wird beide erhalten
plötzlich den offiziellen
Kandidatenstatus der EU auf den man in
Sarajevo seit 2003 gewartet und
hingearbeitet hat ein Schlag der mit
einer weiteren Nachricht einhergeht die
weitaus mehr Bedeutung hat als sie auf
den ersten Blick vermuten lässt
Umgehung von Bosnien die gewaltige
Brücke die den Reiseverkehr auf dem
Balkan verändern wird und damit kommen
wir nun wirklich zum eingangs erwähnten
Küstenstreifen mit der sogenannten
pellishas Brücke will Kroatien den Neo
Korridor umgehen die
fundamentkonstruktion dazu begann
bereits 2007 aber die Arbeiten gerieten
ins Stocken als die Finanzkrise kam dem
Bauträger ging das Geld aus so dass das
Projekt 2012 schließlich sogar
gestrichen wurde dennoch hat Kroatien
seinen Plan zur Umgehung des
neonkorridors auch nie ganz aufgegeben
dass man einen Blick auf diese Karte
bis vor kurzem führte die einzige Straße
von Dubrovnik zum Rest von Kroatien
durch den Neon Korridor und damit ein
kleines Stück durch Bosnien-Herzegowina
bis jetzt war das kein Problem Fahrzeuge
diese Straße passiert noch keinen Pass
und keine Kontrollen um den Korridor zu
durchqueren wenn sie keine Waren oder
Passagiere auf bosnische herzoginischem
Gebiet Abladen wollten aber all das soll
sich ab 2024 ändern wenn Kroatien das
bekommt worauf sich seine
Tourismusbranche lange gefreut hat den
Beitritt zum Schengenraum eine
Voraussetzung für die
schengenmitgliedschaft ist nämlich das
Reisende und ihre Fahrzeuge sowohl bei
der Einreise als auch bei der Ausreise
in der Schengengebiet kontrolliert
werden
allerdings schloss Kroatien die
Einrichtung eines Kontrollpunktes im
neonkorridor aus da dies die ohnehin
schon auftretenden Verkehr Staus noch
verschlimmern würde aus diesem Grund hat
Kroatien beschlossen das Projekt zum Bau
der polierschutzbrücke wieder
aufzunehmen
außerdem zwang die Pandemie die Kroaten
bereits dazu sich den von Bosnien
auferlegten Beschränkungen für den
Transit durch den neonkorrektur zu
beugen und das war ein Grund mehr den
Bau der Pelli schatzbrücke
voranzutreiben
Kroatiens pelier schatzbrücke von der EU
finanziert von China gebaut tja und dann
war es endlich soweit die schatzbrücke
wurde am 26 juli 2022 eingeweiht nicht
zuletzt dank der große gegenbeteiligung
Brüssel ist an den Kosten in Höhe von
375 der notwendigen 525 Millionen Euro
die Baufirma die dieses Geld im
Wesentlichen Fluss war übrigens die
staatliche China road and bridge
Corporation
seit der Fertigstellung dieser 2,4 km
langen Brücke müssen Touristen auf dem
Weg nach Dubrovnik nicht mehr den
neonkorridor und damit zwei
EU-Außengrenzen überqueren doch mit der
Brücke wird Bosnien-Herzegowina nicht
nur umgegangen während der Bauarbeiten
äußerte man in Sarajevo mehrmals die
Sorge dass die Brücke größere Schiffen
den Weg zum Hafen von Neon versperren
könnte daraufhin baute man die Brücke
zwar 55 m höher eine Einschränkung des
Seewegs ist aber dennoch nicht
ausgeschlossen diese Umgehungsstraße
durch welches sich die Bosnia so
umgangen fühlen ist gerade zu einem
Metapher dafür wie die du mit den
möglichen Beitritt Boss den
herzegowina's umgeht und ihn
hinauszögert während andere Bewerber mit
offenen Armen empfangen werden
zweifellos also ein harter Schlag für
alle die geglaubt haben dass ein
Beitritt zur EU die beste Garantie dafür
wäre dass dieser viel völker-bundesstaat
ein geeintes und stabiles Land werden
wird die Perspektiven für Bosnien
Herzegowina sind zurzeit also trotz der
vielen Anstrengungen der letzten Jahre
so trübe wie schon lange nicht mehr auf
der anderen Seite musste ich Brüssel
aber auch die Frage stellen ob es ein
Land mit derart vielen ungelösten
Problemen und so viel Konfliktpotenzial
überhaupt als Mitglied verdauen könnte
dies gilt übrigens auch für Serbien
welches ja ebenfalls Beitritt Ambitionen
hegt potien und mit ihm Verbündete
nationalistische Politiker auf den
Balkan sind dabei gleich eine doppelte
Chance zur Schwächung der EU denn indem
sie den ethnischen Zwist in Bosnien
Serbien und dem Kosovo anheizen
versuchen sie deren eu-beitritte auf der
einen Seite zu verhindern sollten diese
jedoch trotzdem gelingen könnten diese
Länder quasi zu giftpillen zu Spalt
gewissen innerhalb der Union werden und
ihre Handlungsfähigkeit auf lange Zeit
lähmen egal wie dieses Spiel Ausgänge
das alte wie neue Pulverfass Balkan
bietet für Europa schon wieder unendlich
viele Wege zu verlieren aber nur sehr
wenige zu gewinnen daher muss Europa
verdammt gut aufpassen wo es hintritt
und wie es ein Pfad durch dieses
politische Minenfeld wählt aber dies ist
schon wieder ein Thema für ein separates
Video wir werden uns im folgenden Video
unserer balkanreihe deswegen das nächste
interessante Puzzlestück vorknöpfen
Serbien und dessen EU-Pläne vergesst
also bitte nicht das Abo und ganz
wichtig das Glöckchen um nichts mehr zu
verpassen ich danke Euch so und jetzt
frage ich euch sollte die EU darauf
setzen Bosnien Herzegowina einzugliedern
glaubt ihr dass die datenverträge eher
eine Belastung sind oder sind sie für
das Zusammenleben notwendig wie könnte
eine reformiertes Vertragswerk aussehen
welche den Bosnien ein besseres Leben
als bisher ermöglicht wie immer sind wir
auf eure Beiträge und Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses gut was gebracht
hat falls ja gibt uns mit einem like und
teils auch fleißig mit euren Freunden
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit uns hält
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den PayPal
Link dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]